jacques benillouche il est journaliste
indépendant bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france depuis
tel-aviv en moins de quinze jours on l'a
vu israël à vacciner près d'un million
de personnes comment expliquer cette
rapidité
alors d'abord il faut dire que il y
avait un paradoxe c'est que date agneaux
avait été longtemps critiquée au départ
d'une part parce qu'il avait été trop
dur en confinant surtout pendant les
fêtes juives et ensuite en ouvrant
carrément le le je dirais la de tout
tous les commerces surtout dans le
courant du mois de décembre
pendant la fête des lumières ce qu'on
appelle femme ou cas et donc pourquoi
parce qu'il ne voulait pas être mal avec
les orthodoxes collision qui font partis
de sa coalition
alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'il ya
eu depuis une excellente logistique
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne connaît
peut-être pas beaucoup en france parce
que nous les les tous les gens de plus
de 65 ans recevez un sms privé chez eux
leur demandant de venir
ce maxi dé prendre rendez-vous y avait
des rendez vous qui a été fait on
assistait beaucoup et puis quand les
personnes ne se présente et de celle sur
dix on ne s'inscrivait pas il ya une
deuxième une deuxième action
c'était qu'on recevait un coup de fil
privé de la part des centres de
vaccination et en dix ans pour les gens
qui sont fragiles entre autres les
diabétiques et bien il recevait un appel
personnel leur disant il faut venir vous
faire vacciner vous êtes très fragile
donc il ya une action qui a été mise et
ensuite on a mis les moyens
on a mis les moyens parce que la tam
yahoo a eu le flair je dirais de
commander alors que le vaccin n'était
pas validé le vaccin n'était pas encore
accepté par les les organisations
internationales médicale eh bien il a
commandé 8 millions de doses à pfizer 8
millions payé cash un prix très fort
parce qu'ils voulaient être sûrs de les
recevoir et dons qu'il a reçus avant
tout
des vaccins 8 millions il a commandé 8
millions il en a reçu 2 millions d'un
coup de millions ce qui permet de bâtir
et un million et c'est pour ça que et
sans moi de vous couper à peut-être
aussi deux atouts c'est le fait d'être
un petit pays 9 3 millions d'habitants
mais aussi le fait d'avoir une
population qui est majorité en majorité
en faveur de la vaccination on voit un
dernier sondage publié mi décembre
63 % des israéliens sont prêts à se
faire vacciner
absolument ne serait ce parce qu'il ya
une opé une une
disons qu'une action était d'abord avec
lucky correction nous sommes 9 millions
en israël 9 millions sans exactement au
1er janvier selon les statistiques
officielles
bon c'est un petit pays par rapport à la
france mais il n'empêche que il ya eu
des mesures qui ont été prises très très
rapidement alors aujourd'hui on a encore
quelques foyers d'infection qu'ils sont
pas traitées ce sont les villages arabes
et les villes orthodoxe religieuse juive
pour deux raisons au de raison c'est que
il ya une certaine publicité qui a des
fêtes par sa teinte dirigeants arabes
disant qu'il ne fallait pas venir se
vacciner parce que les israéliens allait
inaugurer un poison dans le vaccin
c'est assez bizarre cette politique
parce que il faut savoir qu en israël
30% des mails des milieux médicaux sont
des arabes parce qu'il ya une autre il y
a une politique de discrimination
positive qui fait que dans les
universités médicale il y il est
nécessaire d'avoir 20% d'arabes
donc on comprend mal non s'il vous plaît
il serait là a commandé en tout donc 14
millions de doses certaines sources
affirment que le gouvernement à payer
plus cher les vaccins pour être servi en
premier
tout à fait et je le dis au départ une à
payer ils ont je crois que c'est aux
ordres aux environs de 30 dollars la
dose ce qui est très cher ce qui est
beaucoup trop chère par rapport à ce
qu'on croyait
mais c'est là où justement le coup de
maître de bibi netanyahu sait qu'il a
voulu payer cher pour être
sûrs d'être fournie et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui nous pensons qu'à fin
mars la totalité 70% de la population
sera vaccinée et que donc le virus du
corps la vie du corona sera derrière
nous et la pandémie sera terminée en
israël bien merci beaucoup pour tout ces
informations jacques benillouche je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
indépendant merci à vous